(Applause)
Duality is the ability to hold both things.
But the question is: Can we own our duality?
Can we have the courage to hold both things?
I work at a restaurant in town,
I became really good friends with the busser.
I was a server and we had a great relationship,
we had a really great time together.
Her Spanish was great
because she was from Mexico.
(Laughter)
That line actually went the other way.
Her English was limited, but significantly better than my Spanish.
But we were united by our similarities,
not separated by our differences.
And we were close, even though we came from very different worlds.
She was from Mexico,
she left her family behind so she could come here
and afford them a better life back home.
She was a devout conservative Catholic,
a believer in traditional family values,
stereotypical roles of men and women,
and I was, well, me.
(Laughter)
But the things that bonded us were when she asked about my girlfriend,
or she shared pictures that she had from her family back home.
Those were the things that brought us together.
So one day, we were in the back,
scarfing down food as quickly as we could, gathered around a small table,
during a very rare lull,
and a new guy from the kitchen came over --
who happened to be her cousin --
and sat down with all the bravado and machismo
that his 20-year-old body could hold.
(Laughter)
And he said to her, [in Spanish] "Does Ash have a boyfriend?"
And she said, [in Spanish] "No, she has a girlfriend."
And he said, [in Spanish] "A girlfriend?!?"
And she set down her fork, and locked eyes with him,
and said, [in Spanish] "Yes, a girlfriend. That is all."
And his smug smile quickly dropped to one of maternal respect,
grabbed his plate, walked off, went back to work.
She never made eye contact with me.
She left, did the same thing --
it was a 10-second conversation, such a short interaction.
And on paper, she had so much more in common with him:
language, culture, history, family, her community was her lifeline here,
but her moral compass trumped all of that.
And a little bit later, they were joking around in the kitchen in Spanish,
that had nothing to do with me,
and that is duality.
She didn't have to choose some P.C. stance on gayness over her heritage.
She didn't have to choose her family over our friendship.
It wasn't Jesus or Ash.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Her individual morality was so strongly rooted
that she had the courage to hold both things.
Our moral integrity is our responsibility
and we must be prepared to defend it even when it's not convenient.
That's what it means to be an ally, and if you're going to be an ally,
you have to be an active ally:
Ask questions, act when you hear something inappropriate,
actually engage.
I had a family friend who for years used to call my girlfriend my lover.
Really? Lover?
So overly sexual,
so '70s gay porn.
(Laughter)
But she was trying, and she asked.
She could have called her my friend,
or my "friend," or my "special friend" --
(Laughter) --
or even worse, just not asked at all.
Believe me, we would rather have you ask.
I would rather have her say lover, than say nothing at all.
People often say to me, "Well, Ash, I don't care.
I don't see race or religion or sexuality.
It doesn't matter to me. I don't see it."
But I think the opposite of homophobia and racism and xenophobia is not love,
it's apathy.
If you don't see my gayness, then you don't see me.
If it doesn't matter to you who I sleep with,
then you cannot imagine what it feels like
when I walk down the street late at night holding her hand,
and approach a group of people and have to make the decision
if I should hang on to it or if I should I drop it
when all I want to do is squeeze it tighter.
And the small victory I feel
when I make it by and don't have to let go.
And the incredible cowardice and disappointment I feel when I drop it.
If you do not see that struggle
that is unique to my human experience because I am gay, then you don't see me.
If you are going to be an ally, I need you to see me.
As individuals, as allies, as humans,
we need to be able to hold both things:
both the good and the bad,
the easy and the hard.
You don't learn how to hold two things just from the fluff,
you learn it from the grit.
And what if duality is just the first step?
What if through compassion and empathy and human interaction
we are able to learn to hold two things?
And if we can hold two things, we can hold four,
and if we can hold four, we can hold eight,
and if we can hold eight, we can hold hundreds.
We are complex individuals,
swirls of contradiction.
You are all holding so many things right now.
What can you do to hold just a few more?
So, back to Toledo, Ohio.
I'm at the front of the line,
niece on my shoulders, the frazzled clerk calls me Dad.
Have you ever been mistaken for the wrong gender?
Not even that.
Have you ever been called something you are not?
Here's what it feels like for me:
I am instantly an internal storm of contrasting emotions.
I break out into a sweat that is a combination of rage and humiliation,
I feel like the entire store is staring at me,
and I simultaneously feel invisible.
I want to explode in a tirade of fury,
and I want to crawl under a rock.
And top all of that off with the frustration that I'm wearing
an out-of-character tight-fitting purple t-shirt,
so this whole store can see my boobs,
to make sure this exact same thing doesn't happen.
(Laughter)
But, despite my best efforts to be seen as the gender I am,
it still happens.
And I hope with every ounce of my body that no one heard --
not my sister, not my girlfriend, and certainly not my niece.
I am accustomed to this familiar hurt,
but I will do whatever I need to do to protect the people I love from it.
But then I take my niece off my shoulders,
and she runs to Elsa and Anna --
the thing she's been waiting so long for --
and all that stuff goes away.
All that matters is the smile on her face.
And as the 30 seconds we waited two and a half hours for comes to a close
we gather up our things, and I lock eyes with the clerk again;
and she gives me an apologetic smile and mouths,
"I am so sorry!"
(Laughter)
And her humanity, her willingness to admit her mistake disarms me immediately,
then I give her a: "It's okay, it happens. But thanks."
And I realize in that moment
that I don't have to be
either an aunt or an advocate, I can be both.
I can live in duality, and I can hold two things.
And if I can hold two things in that environment,
I can hold so many more things.
As my girlfriend and my niece hold hands and skip out the front of the door,
I turn to my sister and say, "Was it worth it?"
And she said, "Are you kidding me?
Did you see the look on her face? This was the greatest day of her life!"
(Laughter)
"It was worth the two and a half hours in the heat,
it was worth the overpriced coloring book that we already had a copy of."
(Laughter)
"It was even worth you getting called Dad."
And for the first time ever in my life, it actually was.
Thank you, Boulder. Have a good night.
(Applause)